from 1997 to 2009 the Fox animated
series king of the hill was among the
most consistently funny smart and
sharply satirical shows on TV created by
Mike judge and Craig Daniels it took
place in the all-american Texas town of
Arlen and depicted the lives of propane
salesman Hank Hill my name is Hank Hill
and I sell propane and propane
accessories substitute Spanish teacher
Peggy Hill yo tener mucho demasiado
Beunos a nose and frente para pasar me
vida and paprika Seguros their
one-of-a-kind son Bobby and their
neighbors and friends here are some
things you might not have known about
king of the hill welcome to Arlen after
the success of beavis and butt-head MTV
Fox asked Mike judge to develop an
animated series and that work could pair
with the Simpsons judge who had grown up
in the southwest produced a very rough
idea of a Texas Set series Fox
executives suggested he find a seasoned
comedy writer to help him flesh out a
script so we got together with The
Simpsons Greg Daniels taking him on a
trip to Texas to give him the feel for
the show Daniels added a lot of his own
material to judge his original concept
including the characters of Luanne and
cotton Hill he also added the notion
that Dale was a conspiracy theorist
whose wife was cheating on him then
instead of a pilot episode judge and
Daniel's devised a pencil test in the
two-minute video Hank Hill voiced by
Judge pitched Fox executives are making
a show about his life I got some ideas
for advertisers if you put us on the air
trucks pork rinds we'd a lot of those in
our house what's up with Boomhauer yeah
man I tell you who I mean I've seen dang
ol Draco lay down misma Sounion man of
redneck Lincoln's had ended our chairman
down caveman section they're all it's
almost every episode of king of the hell
the character of Boomhauer remains a
mystery
although he's one of Hanks core group of
beer buddies and appears in most every
episode little is known about him the
fact that his name is Jeff and he's a
Texas Ranger isn't even revealed until
the series finale is also impossible to
understand because he speaks in a rapid
by a Texas drawl take what man don't
take that and DMV meant I'm a picnic
o'hare hoody that day men on for dangle
years we don't go looking at Cokie
Roberts man Mike judge voiced the
character and as he mentioned on an
episode of Jimmy Kimmel Live he based
his technique on an irate TV viewer who
once left him an incomprehensible
voicemail to complain about judges
previous show a beavis and butthead this
message turned out he goes
I've been calling Alfred a month now
grab batch oh every time it banging up
Kobe's butthole from the tail of Dale
the role of chain-smoking conspiracy
theorists and exterminator Dale Gribble
was almost played by Daniel Stern the
home alone star and the Wonder Years
narrator but he reportedly wanted too
much money and producers sent him away
he would have joined a voice cast I was
populated by well-known actors and
experienced vocal talent prepare to be
destroyed by the deadliest of all
martial arts around the same time king
of the hill co-creator Greg Daniels took
in a Comedy Showcase at the Los Angeles
Club where a Texas born comic named
Johnny Hardwick told some stories about
his family and upbringing
after his sets Daniels offered him a job
as a writer on king of the hill once in
the fold Hardwick auditioned for Dale
telling the Austin Chronicle that he
took inspiration for his
characterization from counterculture
icon William s Burroughs and Matthew
McConaughey in Dazed and Confused along
with a bit of Jack Nicholson Hardwick
got the part of course his first ever
acting gig where is Allen the hill
family lives in Arlen a sleepy
medium-sized city in Texas about a
hundred miles from Dallas or is it like
Springfield or Shelbyville in the
Simpsons
Allen isn't a real place the town's name
is reminiscent of Garland a suburb of
Dallas where Mike judge once lived
but while TVs Allen isn't part of a
fictional Dallas Fort Worth Metroplex
judge says the town was really inspired
by Richardson a different Dallas suburb
Dallas I don't want you going to Dallas
at all that place is crawling with
crackheads and debutantes and half of
them play for the Cowboys
despite the shows of general adherence
to continuity in Cannon Island shifts to
a river the story needs it to go
just like dirndl and mcmaynerbury Allen
is nowhere and everywhere at once as
long as that everywhere is in Texas
the unfinished spin-off king of the hill
was a long-running success for Fox with
a large universe of characters so it's
not surprising that in the early 2000s
Fox ordered a pilot for a live-action
spin-off called Monsignor Martinez vaya
con Dios written by king of the hills
Jimdo treif and directed by Mike judge
it starred venezuelan actor evo Koontz
areeda as a trigger-happy avenging
priest at the center of a
spanish-language soap opera popular in
Allen unfortunately while the show had a
complete pilot produced it was never
aired and while it's rumored to have
shown up online long ago it's considered
to be long-lost media today you got
lucky one of the biggest additions to
the later seasons of king of the hill
was Al Roy lucky Kleinschmidt Luanne
sketchy boyfriend and later husband his
nickname comes from his main source of
income a cash settlement he won because
he slipped on a puddle of urine in a
Costco I slipped on pee pee and broke
two vertebrae which had to be fused
together I'm in constant pain but by god
I got me a $53,000 settlement lucky was
voiced by the late rock legend Tom Petty
and he kind of looked like Tom Petty too
which was totally by design when
describing the character to Mike judge
writer John old Shula said lucky or to
look like Tom Petty without the success
so the show's producers actually pursued
petty for the role the rock star who had
very little acting experience outside
his music videos enthusiastically signed
up back from the dead Fox famously
canceled Family Guy in 2002 and then
brought it back in 2005 but most people
don't know that the network did the same
thing with king of the hill the show's
eleventh season finale
Lucky's wedding suit aired in May 2007
and was intended to serve as a
conclusion to the series it's kind of
had to be the last episode of king of
the hill too because Fox had canceled
the show judge told the Chicago Tribune
and I mean completely cancelled as in
everyone moved out and cleaned out their
desks imagine their surprise when Fox
ordered more episodes and king of the
hill ended up running for another two
years the return of Hank
king of the hill rode the proverbial
lawnmower into the Texas Twilight in
September 2009 but on TV these days
everything old is new again at the 2017
Television Critics Association summer
press tour Fox CEO and chairperson Dana
Walden said preliminary conversations
have taken place between the network and
king of the hill creators Mike judge and
Greg Daniels Walden thing's Hank Peggy
and the rest would have a point of view
about America today and she wants to
explore a revival sounds like a pretty
dang ol great idea to us thanks for
watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to
[Music]